hold on one second i'm going to
use my handy orphan alpha sunburn
computation thing
so long as i can get network here there
we go
oh actually you know what it says
sunburn unlikely
this is a qa moment
this is a good moment okay okay well
let's let me just check what it thinks
that i see why it thinks that it doesn't
seem like my intuition this is one of
these cases where we can the question is
do we do
do we trust the science or do we um use
common sense
the uv thing is called the yeah yeah
well we'll see this is a qa moment as i
say
it's uh can we trust the product yes we
trust the product so and then be a data
point
either way if if i'm desperately
sunburned i will send
an angry feedback
you